hey like watch it [ __ ] blow up and
shovin popcorn in your face well guess
who knows how to make those movies you
know who it is it's Michael Bay there's
so much more to this ælis director than
just explosions here are some things
that I guarantee you didn't know about
Michael Bay Bay grew up in Los Angeles
and he quickly developed a keen eye
winning numerous national photography
awards as a teenager one of Bay's first
jobs in Hollywood was an intern for
Lucasfilm organizing story birds for
Raiders of the Lost Ark how awesome is
that while a film student at Wesleyan
College they knew that he wanted to be a
filmmaker after seeing West Side Story
movies Michael Bay saw a West Side Story
and that's the one that inspired him the
style the energy and the camera movement
made this guy want to be a director he
continued to develop that cinematic eye
and then he went to grad school at
Pasadena Art Center College of Design
he made a 1-minute spec commercial which
caught the eye of producers at Capitol
Records he was hired for artists that
include tina turner and vanilla ice his
success directing music videos landed
Bane with a deal at propaganda films
listen to who he was with Spike Jonze
David Fincher Michelle gondry come on so
many different class of directors coming
out and Michael Bay was part of it by
the age of 26 they achieved major
success as a commercial director in the
1990s remember those commercials got
milk
who directed those Michael Bay you
didn't know it well now you do aren't
you glad to hit play Michael Bay
directed his first feature film bad boys
Bane was actually unhappy with the
ending of the movie and he paid back
twenty five thousand dollars of his
directing fee so that he could redo the
scene that's him going I don't give it
I'm gonna go and do the movie I want to
do that's the kind of director he is
they continue to direct the biggest
Hollywood features like Armageddon
The Rock Pearl Harbor and the island
they was personally asked by Steven
Spielberg to direct transformers there
is no denying that Michael Bay's style
is over-the-top
excessive spectacular fast-paced epic
loud and visually aggressive and you
know what sometimes that is what need
and Michael Bay gives that to hey
critics don't like Michael Bay's movies
all the time you know what he doesn't
care his movies have made over five
billion dollars doesn't matter what the
negative reviews say he put butts in the
BAE's new movie 13 hours secret soldiers
of Benghazi is out January 15th go and
see it and see what John Krasinski blows
up I'm Kristian harloff with Fandango
movie clips and thank you for watching
[Music]
you